la baisse des chiffres de la pandémie se
confirme puisque on est encore à -15%
sur les hospitalisations et les
hospitalisations grave par rapport à la
semaine dernière
et puis il ya une vaccination qui
progresse trop lentement à mon goût 1
38% de premières vaccinations et 18
seulement de double vaccination mais
ceci dit les conditions semblent réunies
effectivement pour retourner au travail
d'autant que la santé ce n'est pas que
la santé physique face au co vide c'est
également un état de bien-être
psychologique et je pense que depuis
quinze ans maintenant on a beaucoup
morflé 1 et que les gens effectivement
qui ont subi un travail à la maison
1 ce n'est pas un télétravail tout à
fait ordinaire un travail à domicile
parce qu'il ya d'autres formes de
télétravail mais pour ceux qui ont été
en télétravail
oui un retour pour voir les collègues
devise us extrêmement important d'un
point de vue social et puis je pense
aussi à toutes les personnes qui ont
perdu leur emploi qui sont extrêmement
nombreuses de l'ordre de 400 milliards
en 2020 et là aussi on espère un retour
à l'emploi le plus rapide possible avec
des priorité de réembauche également
pour ceux qui avaient un boulot avant la
crise c'est une très bonne chose le
retour en présentiel c'est pas très joli
mot c'est à dire le retour à une vraie
organisation
je pense que le travail télétravail
d'une mauvaise chose pour les personnes
parce que moi qui en a la moitié qui
était en détresse psychologique à des
moments directeur des ressources
humaines dit que c'est pas bon pour
l'entreprise c'est pas bon effectivement
pour les organisations que les gens
soient éclaté électroniquement dans
différents lieux d une organisation pour
qu'elle soit vivante il faut que les
gens soient les uns près des autres en
lien social et c'est extrêmement
important donc c'est une
oui je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
qu'on arrête le télétravail petit à
petit et plus vite possible sera le
mieux
on voit que les chefs d'entreprise sont
beaucoup plus dubitatif sur le
télétravail qui pouvait l'être il ya un
an
si on continue le télétravail on va
détruire les organisations vivante que
soient les entreprises où la fonction
publique que les mamans près d'une
journée td travail par semaine pour
garder leurs enfants le mercredi c'est
pas un souci mais le reste du temps où
les perses il en avait envie
mais le reste du temps je pense qu'il
est bien que tout le monde soit sur les
lieux de travail le plus possible pour
pouvoir échanger c'est là où il ya la
créativité on sait la machine à café
la bonne ambiance qui se fait le fait
que les gens se connaissent et et que
tout se passe bien donc je pense que il
faut se débarrasser un peu du
télétravail oui le télétravail ça a été
une preuve de quand même de souplesse un
des acteurs économiques c'est-à-dire
qu'il ya un mois je travaille chez
orange par exemple le télé dans les et
les entreprises de télécommunications
le télétravail s'est largement
développée mais voilà c'est il faut pas
forcer les salariés est tout le temps en
télétravail qui est un choix de
effectivement de parfois être en
télétravail
ça peut se comprendre d'autant plus par
exemple lorsque en région parisienne
dans des conditions de transport
extrêmement difficile pénible longues
etc
ça peut se comprendre quand on est en
vie de travail et pas forcément chez soi
mais proche de chez soi il ya des formes
aussi de coworking qui qui existe qui se
sont développées ou des entreprises
multi sites où les salariés aimeraient
se travailler sur un site plus proche de
leur domicile
mais il n'empêche que ce qui est
fondamental et francky c'est un danger
aussi bien pour les employeurs que pour
les salariés que les syndicats que dès
que les rh le fait que du lien social se
tissent de nouveau et je pense que ce
sera pas mal
on a vu pas mal des gens des villes
partir à la campagne ce qui le pouvaient
pour travailler dans meilleures
conditions vont pas être les uns sur les
autres ce qui est le cas largement en
ville donc ça c'est une première
inégalité ans j'irai entre la ruralité
et urbanité femmes sommes aussi là aussi
une différence entre les inégalités même
si elle n'existe plus en théorie de par
la loi et elle existe dans voir la vie
réelle égalité femmes hommes et les
femmes ont payé un lourd tribut pendant
ces quinze mois avec le télétravail
maisons et des wd triple journée après
le fait que nous nombre de travailleurs
de travailler ce soit approprié des
outils numériques c'est plutôt
intéressant pour la suite c'est un outil
parmi d'autres mais voilà faut pas
généraliser le télétravail certainement
pas au télétravail en fait avant
l'épidémie commencé à se développer mais
plus de assez doucement un jour par
semaine très souvent que quelques
personnes pour faciliter et là ça a été
une ruée sur le télétravail
moi je pense que les entreprises se sont
quand même rendu compte en majorité que
c'était une très bonne chose que ce
n'est pas une très bonne chose pour leur
organisation pour la santé psychologique
de leurs salariés pour leur inventivité
et je pense que pour les salariés c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement dangereux je
pense parce que vous voyez quand les
salariés d'une entreprise française
d'orange par exemple d'une autre
entreprise qui télétravaillent tous ils
pourront facilement être remplacé par
d'aider les travailleurs qui travaillent
en tunisie par exemple ou dans d'autres
pays à bas salaires
ça pourrait faire une concurrence assez
forte pour les salariés français et donc
je pense que c'est assez inquiétant de
ce point de vue là et que les salariés
français devraient se battre contre
celui des le travail si facilitera
l'écrasement des salaires par les
multinationales